[Music]
I wanna feel something I wanna feel
something I drink to feel something I
sleep and feel nothing
maybe that's where you come in
maybe that's where you and I begin
[Music]
I want some good loving I want some good
loving wanting to mean something set
this old hard person
maybe that's where you come in
maybe that's what you and I begin
no I don't need a Heavenly heart
a place beyond the clouds with everyone
we've ever known
it don't matter where we go
if you were born around
I was made to run with you
[Music]
I Was Made For You
I need some
need some I need some church darling I
am a false prophet I must confess
darling
maybe that's sweet
[Music]
maybe that's
our love's a great Mountain our love's a
great Mountain
climbed up and fell down here we live to
laugh about it
oh baby you and I survive
maybe God thinks you that I'm alive
no I don't need a Heavenly home
[Music]
a place beyond the clouds with everyone
it don't matter where we go
if you were born
I was made to run with you
[Music]
I wanna feel something I want some good
loving Take Me to Church darling our
love's a great Mountain
well baby after all this time
maybe home is you and I've arrived
[Applause]